[Music]
I just couldn't believe that somebody
would do all that running for no
particular reason this weekend marks 25
years since the release of the iconic
movie Forrest Gump it follows an Army
veteran played by Tom Hanks who runs
across the country well this morning in
our series a more perfect union we have
the story of a 95 year old wolf World
War two vet who is attempting a similar
feat the series aims to show that what
unites us as Americans is far greater
than what divides us Ernie Andrus is
running from coast to coast to raise
money to preserve a ship involved in a
d-day invasion he started in Saint
Simons Island Georgia and is headed to
San Diego nearly 2,400 miles away well
this morning he's in Monticello Florida
about 170 miles into the journey Steve
Hartman caught up with Ernie when he
just got started back in March yeah it's
all been fun so far group pouring rain
getting hot and humid or sweltering heat
Ernie Andres can be faithfully found
running along busy streets and highways
at 6:30 in the morning three days a week
Ernie runs about four and a half miles
on his cross-country journey an
impressive feat for any 95 year old but
this is his second time doing it back in
2016 then 93 year old Ernie Andrus
became the oldest person ever to run
across America a huge crowd joined him
at the end as this world war two sailors
stormed the beach one last time two
fervent chants and flying colors it was
pure joy but in the months after his
celebrated run ernie says he started to
feel like old news i was running three
days a week but it's the same old thing
and i just got a little bored eventually
ernie decided that even at 95 especially
at 95
there's no time to bask in old glory you
need to keep doing what makes your life
worth living which in his case means
returning here to the georgia beach
where his run ended to start a new run
back across the entire country again we
ask you to bless Ernie this day as he
begins this journey in earnest his last
run to the three years run is more like
a Mosin so Ernie expects this one to
take a bit longer
he hopes to reach San Diego sometime
after his hundredth birthday
the man is nothing if not an optimist
when most people think of retirement
they don't think of this well I did more
since I retired I accomplished more I
made more money now people are saying a
95 year old guy can't run across this
[Laughter]
I'm gonna enjoy it anyhow
yo I've done all the runs planned clear
up to 2025 so you played to get there
one way or the other
wheelchair gurney whatever it takes not
in a coffin just like last time Ernie is
dedicating his run to the LST that's the
kind of ship
Ernie served on in the war there's just
one left in its original configuration
and it's open for tours in Evansville
Indiana he's running to raise money and
awareness this shouldn't be forgotten
ship is like a person do you know we
call it the gray lady
sounds like you're in love with this
lady oh yeah as part of my soul honoring
his naval past by steaming ahead toward
the Pacific and in his wake Ernie leaves
behind all the proof you'll ever need
but there's no fun in fading into the
sunset at least not when you could run
into it for CBS this morning Steve
Hartman in st. Simons Island Georgia
another another winner from Steve
Hartman that's where he tells the best
stories but back to honey for a second
so the first one took him three years
Steve calls this when he's given himself
five years more of a mosey a very
accurate description yeah there's a bit
of a mosey if you want to catch up with
Ernie and give him a pat on the back I
think you can do it behind someone like
that Lee yeah a donation as well to
support that that ship that already
served on that's what this is all about